the basic idea is that we have two ways
of learning new information we have
focused and diffused thinking ping-pong
explains how to switch between focused
and diffused thinking in order to
increase your understanding and get
creative wearing tiny shorts and
grunting is optional focused learning
works by looking at a problem set and
trying real hard to get it it's about
actively using every ounce of mental
force to understand the problem that is
in front of us it's like seeing a brick
wall and reasoning it's too hard to just
run through and too tall to climb
diffused learning is just letting your
mind wander without a plan it can deepen
your understanding or trigger new
creative thoughts with diffused learning
your mind might say hey why don't we tie
a bunch of balloons together and just
float over it both processes are
important to maximize your understanding
of a problem you're facing to truly
optimize your learning play ping pong
between the two focus relax focus relax
focus relax the best practice is to
first focus all your attention
ideally shutting off any distractions
like your phone and other noise after
doing this for a while a timer can be
used deliberately stop to focus and let
your mind freely wander this is when the
brain connects what you just focused on
with other information stored in your
memory which leads to deeper thinking
better retention and allows for creative
thoughts to happen painter Salvador Dali
was using the ping-pong technique after
a round of focused work Dali sat on his
armchair to thank and doze off in one
hand he held a big key and the moment he
fell asleep the key dropped the sound of
the key woke him and he would go back to
the canvas to continue his focused work
Steve Jobs broke up his daily thinking
routine by going out for long walks
the ping-pong technique can be useful to
study for tests start with the most
difficult problem once you get stuck
switch to a more simple one while doing
the easier problem your brain will keep
the difficult problem in its working
memory without conscious thought your
brain will look for connections and try
to make sense of the initial more
difficult problem once you are done with
the easy problem go back to the
difficult one maybe it wasn't as
difficult as you thought please use the
comments section below to let us know if
you find this technique useful and
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
receive updates